how much influence you think hillary has
today in america a lot okay
i i do i think a lot well oh bro bro let
me tell you my assessment but again i'm
fully i'm a business guy i'm an
entrepreneur i'm not a guy that's
involved in this world but i will tell
you this
i think
she has a lot of influence and i think
the reason why biden may not step down
if there is even is any influence left
is because of hillary that hillary
will not
she cannot accept
kamala being the first president
i don't think i think if hillary has any
influence
she's probably the one that wakes up
every morning telling biden's assistant
to give him vitamin c to give the
vitamin b12 yeah to give him trt to give
him whatever it is that he's on to just
make it for two and a half more years
because hillary over her dead body to
have kamala be a president before her
anybody
but kamala she would be okay for
michelle to be the first president she
would not be okay with come out being
the first press